Angela, how many times do you actually
launch Sunshine during the day?
>> Probably about 100, I mean,
we are working on it right now.
>> No, no, I mean to check the weather.
>> Oh, maybe three?
>> Do you really feel like
Sunshine's making you amazing?
>> No.
>> That's the problem,
remember the Android creative vision,
make me amazing?
>> Right,
that's why we added those notifications.
>> Exactly.
Notifications are a great way of
bringing Sunshine to the users,
making it just a normal
part of their day.
>> The students spend all that
time building a content provider.
We should show them how useful it is,
and
have them leverage it,
to build a widget.
>> Great idea Dan,
I actually have a bunch of ideas on
how to bring Sunshine to the users.
>> So then, what are you waiting for?